- (screaming)
- (cheering)
THE 13 FINALISTS OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
HAVE BATTLED IT OUT
THROUGH CHILLS...
- MOTHER OF GOD, IT'S COLD!
- YOU CAN USE THIS IF YOU WANT.
AND THRILLS...
- (screaming)
- AND HEARTBREAKING SPILLS...
AH, EW!
IT'S DOWN TO THREE,
BUT ONLY ONE CAN BE NAMED
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY?
WILL IT BE DANIELLE,
THE SOUTHERN BELLE
WITH A FIERCE WALK
AND A FUN PERSONALITY?
- (thud)
- OOH! WHAT'S UP? OOH!
I MEANT TO DO THAT.
FROM THE FIRST
PHOTO SHOOT,
DANIELLE NAILED
SHOT AFTER SHOT,
FROM A STRIKING BALD
CLOSE-UP...
- SHE'S KILLING IT.
- TO HANDLING A FALL.
GORGEOUS!
MOST OF THE TIME, ANYWAY.
OW, OW, OW.
DANIELLE STUCK WITH IT,
THROUGH SPRAINED TOES
AND DEHYDRATION WOES,
AND IMPRESSED THE JUDGES
WITH HER DETERMINATION
TO KEEP FIGHTING
AGAINST ALL ODDS.
GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
I DIDN'T SEE YOU SICK.
- I DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING.
- THANK YOU.
ALONG THE WAY, DANIELLE
HAD HER FRONT TEETH FIXED.
BUT AS A TOP MODEL,
A FLAWLESS FACE
AND DETERMINATION
WILL ONLY GET YOU SO FAR.
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED
CLEAN LIQUID MAKEUP.
SO YOU KNOW
ABOUT THE ACCENT.
I WILL WORK ON THAT.
THE WINNER
OF THIS COMPETITION
HAS TO BE ARTICULATE.
SHE HAS TO SPEAK
ELOQUENTLY.
CAN DANIELLE
SHOW THE JUDGES
SHE CAN COMMUNICATE
WHEN IT REALLY COUNTS?
OR WILL IT BE JOANIE
FROM BEAVER FALLS,
PENNSYLVANIA,
A PREACHER'S DAUGHTER
WITH A REBELLIOUS SIDE?
I...
KINDA DID SOME AMATEUR NIGHTS
AT A STRIP CLUB.
(record needle scratches)
♪♪♪
THE JUDGES WERE BLOWN AWAY
BY HER NATURAL BEAUTY.
YOU NAILED IT.
UNTIL SHE OPENED HER MOUTH.
(elephant trumpets)
I'M SORRY, BUT THAT TOOTH--
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
WITH A LITTLE HELP
AND A LOT OF PAIN...
THE SNAGGLETOOTH
IS NO LONGER.
JOANIE CAME OUT
WITH A BRAND-NEW SMILE.
BUT AFTER A LIFETIME
OF HIDING IT...
YOU'RE GONNA SAY "SMILE,"
YOU GOTTA SMILE.
CAN JOANIE LEARN
TO WORK HER PEARLY WHITES
ENOUGH TO STAND OUT
FROM THE CROWD?
OR WILL IT BE JADE
FROM NEW YORK CITY,
THE SELF-PROCLAIMED
UNDISCOVERED SUPERMODEL?
EVERY TIME I WALK DOWN
THE STREET, I MEAN,
HEADS ARE, LIKE, TURNING,
LIKE, "WHO IS THIS GIRL?"
WITH THAT DIVA DEMEANOR,
SHE COULD STRIKE A FIERCE POSE,
WHICH LED
TO INCREDIBLE PHOTOS.
I'M LOOKING AT YOUR FILM.
I WAS BLOWN AWAY.
THAT'S GORGEOUS.
HER CONFIDENCE HELPED HER
WIN CHALLENGES,
BUT WHEN THINGS
DIDN'T GO SMOOTHLY,
SHE CAME OFF AS ARROGANT
TO THE JUDGES.
THE OTHER ONE,
I DID THE LINES PERFECTLY.
ARE YOU SAYING THIS IS
YOUR WORST ONE?
I THINK THE EYE MAKEUP
WAS VERY--'CAUSE...
YOU JUST CAN'T DO ALL THIS.
JADE, YOU DON'T KNOW IT ALL,
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO JUST
LISTEN AND LEARN.
OH, THAT'S SO PRETTY!
WHEN DID YOU LEARN
HOW TO BECOME SOFT?
I'M LISTENING, I'M WATCHING
AND I'M LEARNING.
WILL THE "UNDISCOVERED
SUPERMODEL"
PROVE TO THE PANEL THAT
SHE HAS THE RIGHT ATTITUDE
TO WIN IT ALL?
FIND OUT TONIGHT
IN THE SEASON FINALE.
WHO WILL BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL?
♪♪♪
EVERYBODY HERE WANTS TO WIN.
WHOEVER WINS,
I'M GONNA BE HAPPY FOR THEM
- NO MATTER WHAT.
- WHO KNOWS?
I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
I FEEL SOMETHING--
SOMETHING'S GONNA HAPPEN.
I JUST FEEL IT.
I DON'T LIKE NOT KNOWING.
I DON'T LIKE SURPRISES.
- OH, MY GOD! (laughing)
- WHAT?!
WHAT, WHAT, WHAT?
JADE, STOP DOING THAT!
(laughing)
JADE!
SORRY!
I'M SORRY, I JUST...
OH, MY GOD!
PLEASE SEND JADE HOME.
(laughs)
HER PERSONALITY SMELLS
LIKE A DIRTY DIAPER.
MY NERVES ARE BAD.
MM-HMM.
I'M SHAKING.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT I'VE EVER BEEN
IN THE BOTTOM TWO.
THE JUDGES STILL STRUGGLE
WITH YOUR SPEECH.
TO BE IN THE BOTTOM TWO
FOR SOMETHING LIKE MY ACCENT
IS REALLY FRUSTRATING TO ME.
I DON'T EVER, EVER WANNA BE
IN THE BOTTOM TWO AGAIN,
'CAUSE IT'S NOT
A GOOD FEELING.
TYRA MAIL!
"PEOPLE THINK
MODELING IS EASY,
BUT THAT'S NOT ALWAYS TRUE.
BUT IF YOU WIN
THIS COMPETITION,
YOUR LIFE WILL BE EASY,
BREEZY AND BEAUTIFUL."
- COMMERCIAL!
- AH!
I GET TO REDEEM MYSELF!
(laughing)
I JUST WANNA REDEEM MYSELF
FROM MY LAST COVERGIRL SHOOT.
LIGHTWEIGHT MAKEUP...
- (bleep)
- CUT!
COVERGIRLS DON'T SAY THAT!
I JUST DON'T WANNA LOOK
LIKE A JACKASS!
AAH!
WHY YOU SCREAMING?
YOU GUYS WANNA COME SIT
AND CHAT FOR A SEC?
YOU GUYS OBVIOUSLY
KNOW YOU'RE DOING
A COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL TOMORROW
AND A PHOTO SHOOT, RIGHT?
YES, YES.
THERE ARE THREE DIFFERENT
COMMERCIALS IN HERE.
YOU'RE NOT DOING
THE SAME THING,
SO I WANT YOU GUYS
TO PICK AN ENVELOPE.
(chuckling)
MEMORIZE THOSE SCRIPTS.
I FEEL LIKE I'M IN SCHOOL
ALL OVER AGAIN.
I AIN'T SLEEPING TONIGHT.
LashExact MASCARA.
I'VE SEEN MYSELF
WINNING THIS COMPETITION
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
I PLAY IT IN MY MIND.
LIKE, THIS IS
THE BIGGEST FINAL EVER--
ADVANCED BIOLOGY,
DUE TOMORROW.
MY LIFE IS RIDING
ON THIS RIGHT NOW.
WITH NEW COVERGIRL
LashExact MASCARA,
THE CLUMP STOPS HERE.
Lash Exact.
- THAT IS A TONGUE TWISTER.
- EXACT.
I'M NOT GOING HOME
BECAUSE I HAVE AN ACCENT.
THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
- GOOD MORNING.
- MORNING.
- HOW YOU GUYS FEELING?
- GOOD.
- YOU READY?
- MM-HMM.
LOOK AT ME. HOW WELL DO YOU
GUYS KNOW YOUR SCRIPTS?
I MEAN, ARE YOU ALLOWED
TO IMPROVISE?
NO.
SO YOU CAN'T IMPROVISE?
OKAY.
I NEED YOU
TO LEARN THEM VERBATIM.
WHOEVER WINS "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS GONNA HAVE
THIS AD THEY SHOOT TODAY
KICKIN' OFF YOUR CAREER.
SO YOU GOTTA FEEL PRETTY.
YOU NEED TO SELL IT.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
DO YOUR PHOTO SHOOT.
SO TO SHOOT YOUR BEAUTY SHOT
- IS MY BOY JIMMY DE YONKER.
- HEY, GUYS.
JIM HAS SHOT
SO MANY PICTURES OF TYRA.
I CAN'T EVEN TELL YOU.
AND THEY'RE PROBABLY
HER FAVORITE PICTURES EVER.
EYELASHES ARE REALLY
TOUGH TO SHOOT,
SO YOU GUYS GOTTA
HAVE, LIKE, THIS FUN,
SPIRITED LOOK IN YOUR EYE.
IF YOU DON'T
CONVEY THAT MESSAGE
RIGHT THROUGH YOUR EYES,
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK.
- JADE, LEARN THOSE LINES.
- OKAY.
I'M GOING
TO LEARN THE LINES.
- THAT'S--
- THE MAIN PRIORITY.
- YOUR MAIN PRIORITY
RIGHT THERE.
- I KNOW.
THE GIRLS ARE NERVOUS
BECAUSE JADE'S WORRIED
SHE CAN'T MEMORIZE
ALL THOSE LINES,
AND DANIELLE'S
WORRIED ABOUT HER ACCENT,
AND I'VE ALWAYS
HIDDEN MY TEETH.
AND NOW THAT I HAVE
A BETTER SMILE,
I'M STILL NOT
COMFORTABLE IN THESE TEETH.
YOU'RE ALWAYS TALKING
DIRECTLY TO THAT LENS.
OKAY.
LET'S GET READY
TO START IN ONE.
AND ACTION.
WANT TO FIND
FULL AND FLIRTY LASHES?
START WITH NEW COVERGIRL
LashExact MASCARA.
RIGHT NOW YOU'RE GOING,
"WANT TO FIND FULL
AND FLIRTY LASHES?"
THAT'S A CARICATURE
OF JOANIE.
- HMM.
- GIVE ME JOANIE.
DON'T GIVE ME WHAT YOU THINK
A COVERGIRL SHOULD BE LIKE.
AND ACTION.
THE CLUMP STOPS HERE
WITH THE REVOLUTIONARY
THERMOPLASTIC
LashExact BRUSH,
GIVING YOU A FRESH, CLEAN
APPLICATION EVERY TIME.
AND CUT.
- WHOO!
- BEAUTIFUL READ!
I JUST FEEL THAT I HAVE
A LOT OF POTENTIAL,
AND I THINK THAT
PEOPLE SEE THAT IN ME
AND THEY EXPECT MORE FROM ME.
AND ACTION.
DON'T YOU LADIES WANNA HAVE
A CASUAL,
BEAUTIFUL MASCARA
THAT YOU CAN PUT ON
YOUR EYELASHES LIKE MINE?
WELL, I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE
TO YOU TODAY, UM...
CUT. I DON'T KNOW WHERE
YOU GOT THAT FROM, GIRL,
- BUT IT WAS NOT
WHAT WAS WRITTEN HERE.
- I KNOW, I KNOW.
JADE DID NOT KNOW
HER LINES AT ALL.
- AN UNBELIEVABLE BRUSH--
- CUT.
SHE ADDED HER OWN WORDS.
NOR, AS YOU SEE MINE,
ARE VERY BEAUTIFUL.
I NEED A COMMERCIAL
OUT OF YOU TODAY, JADE.
DID YOU KNOW
THIS LITTLE MASCARA--
CUT.
YEAH.
SORRY.
ALL RIGHT,
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS WE'RE GONNA PULL OUT
CUE CARDS FOR YOU.
WHEN THE CUE CARDS CAME OUT,
I WAS LIKE... "WHEW."
START WITH THE NEW COVERGIRL
Exact MASCARA.
CUT.
YOU DIDN'T SAY
WHAT WAS ON THE CARDS.
- I DIDN'T?
- NO.
IF ANYTHING, KNOW THE PRODUCT
YOU'RE SELLING,
LashExact MASCARA.
THE NEW, THE LATEST
COVERGIRL La-Lash--
- CUT.
- NEW COVERGIRL Lash...
CUT.
- NEW COVERGIRL Exact MASCARA--
- CUT.
CAN YOU READ THE CUE CARDS?
CAN YOU SEE THEM?
- Lash Expre--
- CUT.
- Lash Expr--
- LashEx--Exact...
- CUT.
- DO NOT GET DEFEATED.
- (groaning)
JADE, COME ON,
LET'S SHAKE THIS OFF.
I'M NOT A FAILURE.
I DON'T GIVE UP.
I'M A SOLE SURVIVOR.
AND ACTION.
WANT A MORE CASUAL
MASCARA LOOK?
START WITH THE NEW COVERGIRL
LashExact MASCARA.
THE WIRELESS,
TAPERED BRISTLE BRUSH
DELIVERS CLUMP-FREE APPLICATION
THAT WON'T SMEAR OR SMUDGE.
JADE, THAT WAS SO GOOD!
OH, MY GOD,
THAT WAS SO GOOD.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
AS MUCH AS JADE
FLUBBED ALL OVER THE PLACE,
WHEN IT CAME DOWN TO THE WIRE,
SHE DID A REALLY,
REALLY GOOD JOB.
- YOU REMEMBER ALL YOUR LINES?
- YEP.
IT WORKED OUT PERFECTLY.
GOOD JOB.
PATENT.
- NAH, IT'S NOT PATENT.
- IT'S PATENT.
PEN, PEN--
(Southern accent)
HAM AND CHITLINS.
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
MAKING FUN OF YOU.
NO, I-I-I'M THANKFUL.
I'M NOT SAYING TAKE DANIELLE
TOTALLY OUT OF THE PICTURE.
- MM-HMM.
- I JUST WANT YOU
TO JUST CLEAN IT UP.
RIGHT.
TODAY WAS THE FIRST DAY
THAT IT ACTUALLY SUNK IN
AS TO WHERE I AM
AND WHAT I'M DOING.
PATENT-PENDING BRUSH.
AND ACTION.
WANT AMAZING LASHES WITH--
WANT AMAZING LASHES WITH...
CUT. IF YOU MAKE
A MISTAKE, KEEP GOING.
KEEP GOING.
I WENT BLANK.
AND ACTION.
WANT AMAZING LASHES
WITH...
CUT.
WHAT?
WHAT IS WRONG WITH ME?
DANIELLE'S GREAT, YOU KNOW.
SHE'S GOT A GREAT
PERSONALITY, BEAUTIFUL LOOK.
WITH HER ACCENT,
YOU KNOW,
KNOWING THAT SHE HAS TO
CHANGE THAT TO BE A COVER GIRL,
IT'S SUCH
A DISTRACTION FOR HER.
WANT AMAZING LASHES
WITH LOTS OF--WITH....
IT'S ALL IN MY HEAD.
LIKE, I'M BLANK.
IF I CANNOT DO COVERGIRL,
THEN I CAN'T DO
THIS COMPETITION.
♪♪♪
SIMPLY PLACE THE REVOLUTIONARY
PATENT-PENDING BRUSH
AT LASH LINE...
FOR SOME REASON, THE MOMENT
THE CAMERA TURNED ON,
I TURNED OFF.
I KNEW I KNEW MY LINES,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
IN MY HEAD
I KEPT SAYING, "DANIELLE,
DON'T LET YOUR ACCENT
COME OUT."
SOMEHOW YOU GOTTA FIND
THAT ENERGY WITHIN YOURSELF
AND JUST BRING IT BACK.
ACTION, DANIELLE.
WANT AMAZING LASHES WITH LOTS
OF LENGTH AND DEFINITION?
WITH NEW COVERGIRL
LashExact MASCARA,
THE CLUMPS STOPS HERE.
SIMPLY PLACE THE REVOLUTIONARY
PATENT-PENDING BRUSH
AT LASH LINE.
IN A SLOW, EVEN MOTION,
GO FROM ROOTS TO TIPS.
CUT. OH, MY GOD,
I HELD MY BREATH!
WHOO, GIRL!
YOU AT LEAST GOT IT
OUT OF YOUR MOUTH.
LET'S GO, GIRL.
YOU'RE DONE.
I'M STRUGGLING,
SO I HAD TO, LIKE,
STEP MY GAME UP
TO PROVE MYSELF.
WE'LL FOCUS IN
ON YOUR EYELASHES.
- RIGHT.
- OKAY?
SO I NEED YOU JUST TO COCK
YOUR HEAD UP A LITTLE BIT.
WHEN I'M SHOOTING TODAY,
I'M THINKING ABOUT MY MOM,
'CAUSE WHENEVER I THINK
ABOUT MY MOM, YOU KNOW,
A SMILE
COMES ACROSS MY FACE.
TRY NOT TO SMILE SO BIG,
LIKE, MORE OF A...
YEAH, THAT'S PRETTY.
THAT'S GOOD. NICE.
STEP ON IN, JOANIE.
I'VE ALWAYS HIDDEN
MY REAL SMILE.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE HAVING FUN.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO GET THAT, LIKE,
THAT LITTLE SPARK
IN YOUR EYE.
IT'S HARD FOR ME
BECAUSE I'M SMILING
AND IT'S ALMOST LIKE
A FAKE SMILE
BECAUSE I'M NOT USED TO
THIS KIND OF SMILE YET.
- DON'T BE SHY TO SMILE.
- OKAY.
THAT'S REALLY PRETTY.
STUNNING. GREAT.
- OKAY, WE GOT THE SHOT.
- (grunts)
♪ EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL ♪
PLEASE HIRE ME, COVERGIRL.
I'M DEFINITELY MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE COVERGIRL PHOTO SHOOT
BECAUSE MODELING
COMES NATURAL TO ME.
NOT TOO DIVA NOW.
IT'S NOT DIVA.
HE DIDN'T REALLY HAVE
TO GIVE ME TOO MUCH DIRECTION.
GOOD.
YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE CHOKING YOURSELF.
GREAT. OKAY.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT?
I'M THINKING ABOUT
WINING THIS COMPETITION!
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT?
GOOD.
- COOL?
- YEAH.
TYRA MAIL.
"TODAY, YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY TWO WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL. TYRA."
- DANG!
- WOW.
WELCOME, LADIES.
HELLO.
THE FINAL THREE.
BUT, OF COURSE,
THERE CAN ONLY BE TWO
THAT ARE THE TRUE FINALISTS,
AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING
TO DETERMINE TODAY.
THE FIRST JUDGE IS THE NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER...
RUNWAY DIVA COACH EXTRAORDINAIRE
MISS J. ALEXANDER...
FASHION ICON AND
LIVING LEGEND TWIGGY.
HELLO.
AND ROJ SINGHAKUL OF ISSUE,
THE TOP DESIGNER HERE
IN THAILAND.
AND HIS TRANSLATOR TODAY
IS PRIYANUK PUNTONG.
TODAY WE'RE
GONNA EVALUATE YOU.
AFTER THAT, THE JUDGES
WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE
WHICH OF YOU TWO
WILL BE THE FINALISTS.
AND THOSE TWO FINALISTS
WILL BE WALKING
IN A FASHION SHOW
FOR THE DESIGNER ISSUE.
ALL RIGHTY,
SO LET'S START WITH JADE.
OH, GOODNESS, ME,
OH, MY.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, JADE, SO YOU
HAD A COVERGIRL PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU WERE SELLING MASCARA,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
PICTURE OF YOU, JADE.
I'M NOT SURE IT STRIKES ME
AS 100% COVERGIRL.
THERE'S SOMETHING HIDDEN
BEHIND THAT EXPRESSION.
I LIKE IT. I THINK YOU LOOK
VERY PRETTY AND VERY SOFT.
ALL RIGHTY, JADE, SO YOU
HAD A COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL,
AND HERE YOU ARE.
WANT A MORE CASUAL
MASCARA LOOK?
START WITH THE NEW COVERGIRL
LashExact MASCARA.
THE WIRELESS,
TAPERED BRISTLE BRUSH
DELIVERS CLUMP-FREE
APPLICATION.
IT'S PERFECT
FOR A DAYTIME LOOK.
FOR MORE TIPS AND TRICKS
LIKE THESE,
CHECK OUT covergirl.com.
ALL RIGHT, JADE,
SO THERE'S A LOT OF THIS...
I FELT LIKE I WAS IN INDIA
FOR A SECOND, NOT THAILAND.
BUT WHAT I DID LIKE
IS WHEN YOU SAID,
"CHECK OUT covergirl.com."
THAT WAS CUTE.
(speaking Thai)
ROJ SAID YOU HAVE A REALLY
BEAUTIFUL SMILE,
BUT HE DOESN'T WANNA BUY
YOUR MASCARA, BASICALLY.
(laughing)
THAT'S FINE.
YOU KNOW, IT IS
MY FIRST COMMERCIAL,
AND I HAVEN'T BEEN TAUGHT
BY AN ACTING COACH.
I THINK ACTING IS
AN AMAZING TALENT TO WITHHOLD.
IT INSPIRES ME--
ACTORS.
ACTRESSES INSPIRE ME,
AS WELL AS YOU, TYRA.
- AND... SCENE.
- I COULDN'T BELIEVE
YOU JUST WENT THERE!
I-I COULDN'T EITHER.
YOU'VE GOTTA LEARN TO ZIP
AT CERTAIN TIMES.
'CAUSE, JADE,
THROUGHOUT THIS COMPETITION,
WE'VE GIVEN YOU THE TOOLS
TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER
A COMMERCIAL.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
I LOVE ABOUT YOU?
GIRL, YOU ARE CONSISTENT.
- JADE, THANK YOU.
- THANK YOU.
UP NEXT IS JOANIE.
SO, JOANIE, YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT FOR COVERGIRL
SELLING MASCARA, AND HERE'S
YOUR BEST SHOT.
PRETTY TIGHT IN THE MOUTH.
(imitates Joanie)
MM-HMM. HMM.
I LOVE IT.
IT'S VERY CLASSIC,
WHICH I WOULD THINK
COVERGIRL WOULD LOVE.
I THINK YOU KNOW HOW TO PLAY
WITH YOUR EYES VERY WELL.
I LIKE IT.
SO, JOANIE,
YOU HAD A COMMERCIAL,
AND HERE IS YOUR TAKE.
WANT TO FIND FULL
AND FLIRTY LASHES?
START WITH NEW COVERGIRL
LashExact MASCARA.
THE CLUMP STOPS HERE
WITH THE REVOLUTIONARY
THERMOPLASTIC
LashExact BRUSH.
NO CLUMPS ON THE BRUSH,
NO CLUMPS ON YOUR LASHES.
FOR MORE TIPS AND TRICKS
LIKE THESE,
CHECK OUT covergirl.com.
I THOUGHT YOU LOOKED
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS, JUST--
- YOU LOOKED LIKE GRACE KELLY.
- YES.
YOU PROBABLY DON'T KNOW
WHO GRACE KELLY WAS BUT...
SHE WAS A DANCER, RIGHT?
"SHE WAS A DANCER"?
CHILD...
NO, NO, NO, SHE WAS
A VERY BIG FILM STAR.
AND A PRINCESS.
THANKS.
JOANIE,
YOU TOOK MY BREATH AWAY.
BUT IN THE VERY END,
I'M NOT GONNA KNOW
WHAT WEB SITE THAT IS,
'CAUSE YOU JUST THREW IT AWAY.
(speaking Thai)
HE SAID THAT YOU HAVE
A VERY BEAUTIFUL SMILE,
BUT IN THERE,
IT KIND OF STILL LOOKS...
STIFF.
ALL RIGHT, JOANIE.
THANK YOU.
AND, DANIELLE.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE
WALKING TO THE PLANK.
NO, I'M WALKING TO YOU GUYS.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
DANIELLE,
YOU MAKE ME WANNA MELT.
YOUR FILM WAS
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
THE ONE CRITIQUE
I WOULD GIVE YOU
IS TO DO THE SQUINT
WITH THE EYES
WHEN YOU WANT A LITTLE BIT MORE
FRIENDLINESS AND CONNECTION.
SO RIGHT NOW, TO ME,
IN THIS PICTURE YOU'RE GOING...
INSTEAD OF...
ALL RIGHTY, DANIELLE,
SO YOU HAD A COMMERCIAL.
WANT AMAZING LASHES WITH LOTS
OF LENGTH AND DEFINITION?
WITH NEW COVERGIRL
LashExact MASCARA,
THE CLUMP STOPS HERE.
SIMPLY PLACE
THE REVOLUTIONARY
PATENT-PENDING BRUSH
AT LASH LINE.
IN A SLOW, EVEN MOTION,
GO FROM ROOTS TO TIPS.
FOR MORE TIPS AND TRICKS
LIKE THESE,
CHECK OUT covergirl.com.
I THINK FOR ME, DANIELLE,
THAT WAS THE MOST
PERSONABLE ONE WE'VE SEEN.
I'VE HAD TERRIBLE TROUBLE
UNDERSTANDING
A LOT OF WHAT YOU'VE SAID.
BUT I DID UNDERSTAND YOU,
AND YOU WERE OBVIOUSLY TRYING.
BUT YOU'VE GOTTA GO
FURTHER.
I HAVE TO SAY,
DANIELLE, I DIDN'T LIKE IT.
I DIDN'T LIKE IT AT ALL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO TELL YOU, YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE WHERE WE COME FROM
AND THE NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT WE COME FROM,
IT'S INGRAINED IN US, YOU KNOW.
BUT YOU HAVE TO KNOW
HOW TO...
LEAVE IT BEHIND
AND TURN IT ON FOR TELEVISION.
I'M NOT SAYING TO SAY,
(Valley Girl accent)
"COVERGIRL LashExact
IS SO NICE."
(normal voice)
YOU COULD STILL USE SOUL,
YOU COULD STILL SAY,
(Southern accent)
"AND IT WON'T CLUMP."
(normal voice) YOU KNOW,
YOU COULD STILL DO THAT,
BUT IT'S NOT...
(Southern accent)
"BUT IT WON'T CLUMP."
(normal voice)
YOU UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE?
ALL RIGHTY, SO NOW
IT'S TIME FOR US TO DECIDE
WHO THE TWO FINALISTS
WILL BE.
DANIELLE.
THAT AMAZING PICTURE
OF DANIELLE.
SHE'S DEFINITELY GOT
THE COVERGIRL LOOK.
HER SKIN
LOOKS LIKE A DREAM.
(speaking Thai)
ROJ THINKS THAT HE WOULD BUY
WHATEVER SHE SELLS IN THIS.
BUT THEN WHEN SHE START TALKING,
IT WAS LIKE... "OKAY."
IT'S SO FUNNY THAT EVEN
IN A DIFFERENT LANGUAGE,
HE CAN STILL SEE THAT
DANIELLE'S SPEECH IS OFF.
A LITTLE BIT OF VOICE COACHING
AND I THINK--
SHE COULD HAVE TEA
WITH THE QUEEN, DARLING.
(British accent)
YEAH, WELL, SHE'S ALREADY
HAD TEA WITH ME ONCE SO...
(laughing)
JOANIE.
THIS IS THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
PICTURE THAT HE LIKES.
SHE HAS THAT
VERY OLD MOVIE STAR QUALITY.
SHE DOES LOOK LIKE A COVER GIRL
BACK IN THE DAY.
LIKE CHRISTIE BRINKLEY
OR SOMETHING?
- YES.
- YES, EXACTLY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S FRESH.
IT MIGHT NOT BE
MODERN ENOUGH.
BUT IN ENGLAND AND EUROPE,
THE SOPHISTICATED LOOK
IS VERY, VERY HOT.
JOANIE JUST CAN'T
TAKE A BAD PICTURE.
NOW, JADE, SHE IS SET
IN BEING THAT MODEL
THAT KNOWS EVERYTHING.
EVEN TODAY,
WE SAID SOMETHING,
AND SHE ANSWERED BACK.
BUT YET, JADE HAS TAKEN
LOADS OF GOOD PICTURES.
SHE HAS DONE SOME
AMAZING PHOTOGRAPHS.
EVEN I'VE HAD TO ADMIT THAT.
THREE BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
THREE LADIES
THAT HAVE COME A LONG WAY.
BUT I ONLY HAVE TWO PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE TWO YOUNG LADIES
THAT WILL COMPETE
IN AN ISSUE FASHION SHOW.
AND ONE OF THEM WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST FINALIST
IS...
♪♪♪
THREE BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
TWO PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
THE FIRST FINALIST
IS...
JOANIE.
CONGRATULATIONS, JOANIE.
THERE'S A 50% CHANCE
THAT YOU WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THAT'S GREAT. (laughs)
YOU SHOULD BE
VERY PROUD OF YOURSELF.
DON'T COVER THE SMILE.
WILL DANIELLE AND JADE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE
ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL
THAT WILL BE A FINALIST
AND WILL COMPETE
WITH JOANIE
TO SEE WHO CAN BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL ONLY
CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT
I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOTEL,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
DANIELLE AND JADE,
BOTH OF YOU HAVE TAKEN
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL PICTURES
THROUGHOUT THIS COMPETITION.
DANIELLE, AS BEAUTIFUL
AS YOUR PICTURES ARE,
THAT VOICE CANNOT
NECESSARILY SELL MAKEUP.
I'VE NEVER SEEN IT DONE
IN MY ENTIRE CAREER.
JADE, THE JUDGES
LOVE YOUR PICTURES.
BUT EVERY TIME YOU COME IN
HERE, THEY FEEL LIKE
YOU HAVE AN EXCUSE
AFTER EXCUSE AFTER EXCUSE.
HOW YOU JUST...
FIDGETED JUST THEN--
YOU'RE STILL TALKING.
STILL.
DANIELLE, CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE A FINALIST,
AND YOU'RE GONNA BE IN
A FASHION SHOW WITH JOANIE,
WEARING BEAUTIFUL CLOTHING
BY ISSUE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
- AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
- THANK YOU.
THANKS, JADE.
THANKS, LADIES.
THANK YOU.
THE REGRETS
WILL PROBABLY BE THAT I THINK
THAT THEY MADE A WRONG CHOICE
IN WHO THEY'RE GONNA SELECT
TO BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE JUDGES OVERLOOKED
MY ABILITY,
AND MY CONFIDENCE WAS DEFINITELY
MISTAKEN FOR ARROGANCE.
IT SMELLS LIKE
SOMETHING HAS DIED IN HERE.
I HAVE WHAT IT TAKES.
IT'S JUST THAT MY LOOK
IS IN A DIFFERENT REALM.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
HOW TO HANDLE IT.
THIS FACE WILL DEFINITELY
BE HARD TO FORGET.
JADE WILL BE
HARD TO FORGET.
AND I JUST WANNA LEAVE
WITH SOME WORDS,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S JUST WHAT I DO.
"LEFTOVER LADY, LET ALONE
THE STRONGEST TO BE SUBDUED,
IF I ONLY HAD THE MAGIC KEY
THAT WOULD UNLOCK
THE REALMS
TO THE PLATEAU
OF THE HIGHEST ME,
EVEN THOUGH I'VE BEEN
BADLY BRUISED,
LIVIN' IN A HOUSE
TO BECOME A POPULAR MUSE."
(laughs)
♪♪♪
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE MADE IT.
FROM 13,
AND THEN THERE WERE TWO.
THEN THERE WERE TWO,
AND IT'S US, MAN.
EBONY AND IVORY, SUCKER.
BEIN' IN THE TOP TWO
IS ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
GOD, YOU DON'T KNOW THE FEELING
THAT RAN THROUGH MY BODY
WHEN SHE PULLED
MY PICTURE OVER.
THAT WAS ROUGH ON ME.
I'M GETTING
CALLED FIRST A LOT.
IS THAT GOOD?
DOES THAT MEAN, LIKE...
HECK, YEAH.
IT'S LIKE YOU WERE
THE BEST OUT OF THE BUNCH.
I JUST HOPE I WIN, SORRY.
WHAT, SUCKER?
DO YOU WANNA GET STABBED
WITH THIS SPOON IN YOUR JUGULAR?
IN MY JUGULAR.
TYRA MAIL.
♪ AAH ♪
"YOUR BODY IS YOUR TEMPLE.
WORK IT,
AND MAKE ME PROUD."
OH, WE THE FINAL TWO.
WE THE FINAL TWO.
FINAL TWO, OW.
FINAL TWO.
WE THE FINAL TWO.
♪♪♪
LOOK AT
MY TWO LITTLE FINALISTS.
- YOU GUYS EXCITED?
- YEAH.
TODAY
IS THE DECIDING MOMENT.
THIS IS THE FINAL RUNWAY.
THIS IS A HUGE FASHION SHOW
FOR THE DESIGNER ISSUE.
WE HAD TO CREATE
THE MOST GORGEOUS RUNWAY EVER
IN TOP MODEL HISTORY.
LOOK AT IT RIGHT HERE.
IT WAS AN ANCIENT CITY,
LIKE, OVER WATER ON A DECK.
JUST THE MOST BEAUTIFUL THING
YOU'VE EVER SEEN IN YOUR LIFE.
HOLY COW, IT'S SO BIG.
I MEAN,
IS THIS NOT ILL?
- THIS IS HUGE.
- THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
THIS IS BIGGER THAN ANYTHING
I'VE EVER SEEN, EVER.
SO YOU GUYS ARE COMIN' OUT
ALL THE WAY OVER THERE,
LET'S BRING OUT MADAME.
- OH, MY.
- THERE SHE IS, THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU'RE GONNA WALK THE PATH,
GO ALL THE WAY AROUND.
LITERALLY, THE RUNWAY
JUST CONNECTS A PATHWAY
FROM TEMPLE
TO TEMPLE TO TEMPLE.
AND IT'S ALL THESE WINDS
AND THESE TWISTS,
AND YOU GOTTA WALK
BETWEEN THESE DOORWAYS,
AND EVERYTHING IS
JUST AMAZING.
YOU'RE WALKING
AUDIENCE LEVEL.
YOU'RE NOT WALKING ON
A RAISED PLATFORM.
WE SEE EVERY SINGLE DETAIL
FROM YOUR TOES
TO YOUR FINGERTIPS
TO THE STUMBLE
TO THE CRUMBLE.
TO THE SWEAT
ROLLIN' OFF YOUR BACK,
'CAUSE LET ME TELL YOU...
BABY, AND THE SWEAT WILL BE
ROLLIN 'OFF YOUR BACK,
'CAUSE RIGHT NOW
IT'S ROLLIN' OFF MY FOREHEAD.
AND IT'S HOT.
IT'S ABOUT 99 DEGREES TODAY,
AND THIS SHOW
IS AN AFTERNOON SHOW.
WE NEED GREAT WALKS.
MAKE IT WORK.
BUILD IT UP, BUST IT OUT.
I FEEL LIKE CRYING,
I FEEL LIKE SCREAMING,
I FEEL LIKE SMILING.
I WANNA WIN SO, SO BADLY.
MY MOM, MY SISTERS, MY BROTHER,
MY DAD, ESPECIALLY MY DAD--
I WANT HIM TO BE,
LIKE, "OH, MY GOSH.
MY DAUGHTER IS THE BEST
IN THE NATION RIGHT NOW."
SO MANY EMOTIONS ARE RUNNIN'
THROUGH MY MIND RIGHT NOW
FROM THINKIN' ABOUT
MY MOM AND HER BEIN' SICK
WITH RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS
TO, YOU KNOW,
ME BEIN' 12 YEARS OLD AND
SEEIN' MY FIRST FASHION SHOW.
I'M SO CLOSE.
LIKE, I'M RIGHT HERE
IN FRONT OF IT,
AND I WANT THIS SO BAD,
WORDS CAN'T EVEN EXPLAIN
HOW BAD I WANT THIS.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHT, GIRLS,
HAIR AND MAKEUP,
HAIR AND MAKEUP.
FASHION SHOW TIME.
- I'M SO EXCITED.
- ME, TOO.
THIS IS, LIKE, MY FIRST
REAL BONA FIDE RUNWAY SHOW.
30 PROFESSIONAL MODELS.
I DON'T CARE HOW MANY YEARS
THEY HAVE OVER ME.
THIS IS MY STAGE.
THIS IS MY TIME TO SHINE.
I'M GONNA BE A MESS UP THERE
ON THAT STAGE TODAY.
♪♪♪
OOH, THIS IS GORGEOUS.
HELLO.
HI.
IT'S A LONG, LONG RUNWAY.
I THOUGHT THE VICTORIA'S SECRET
RUNWAY IS LONG--
THIS ONE IS A WHOLE
'NOTHER THING.
YOU CANNOT SHOW THAT
AUDIENCE THAT YOU'RE HOT.
YOU CANNOT SHOW THEM
THAT YOU'RE TIRED.
YOU'RE GONNA BE TIRED,
BUT I DON'T WANNA SEE THAT.
RIGHT.
OKAY.
OKAY? GIVE ME A HUG.
ALL RIGHTY, WORK IT.
THERE ARE A TON
OF PEOPLE OUT THERE,
LOTS OF ENERGY,
FAST WALKS.
REMEMBER, THE FLOWERS
ARE A LITTLE SLIPPERY.
I'VE GOT ONE CHANCE
TO DO THIS.
THIS EMOTION
JUST RUNS THROUGH MY BODY.
THIS IS REAL. LIKE, THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY REAL.
MY HEART'S
CONSTANTLY RACING.
WHEW. I NEED TO STAY CALM.
THIS COULD BE
MY BREAKING POINT.
♪♪♪
♪ NE-NA, NE-NA ♪
YEAH!
(woman singing in Thai)
WE ARE AT THE GRAND FINALE--
THE LAST RUNWAY SHOW.
THIS IS EITHER GONNA MAKE ME,
OR IT'S GONNA BREAK ME.
YEAH, SHE DOES.
VERY RELAXED, VERY NATURAL.
♪♪♪
OW!
IT'S A VERY,
VERY HARD RUNWAY TO WALK,
BECAUSE THEY HAVE FLOWERS
ON TOP OF THE RUNWAY.
I HAD A FEW MOMENTS
WHERE I SLIPPED,
BUT I DIDN'T LET THAT SHOW.
WHOO!
YAY!
I'M STANDING THERE WAITING,
THE MUSIC'S GOIN',
YOU SEE ALL THE MODELS
AHEAD OF YOU GOIN' OUT,
I'M GOIN', "OH, MY GOD,
OH, MY GOD, THIS IS IT."
TYRA IS WAITING.
YOU CAN'T GO BACK.
GO.
♪♪♪
GIRL, YOU CANNOT
WALK THAT SLOW.
- LOOK WHERE THEY ARE.
- SLIPPING.
GO, GO, GO, GO, GO!
♪♪♪
WHOO!
IT IS SO MUCH FUN OUT THERE.
WE'RE ALL HOT.
WE ARE LITERALLY
HOT AND SWEATING.
WHOO!
GO CHANGE,
GO CHANGE, GO CHANGE.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW
HOW JOANIE'S DOIN',
AND AT THIS POINT IN TIME,
HONESTLY,
I REALLY DON'T CARE
HOW JOANIE'S DOIN',
'CAUSE I'M FOCUSED
ON DANIELLE.
GETTING DRESSED BACKSTAGE
IS LIKE A TORNADO.
PEOPLE ARE PULLING
THINGS OUT OF MY HAIR
AND STICKING THINGS
IN MY EARS.
THIS IS
YOUR LAST PASS, GIRLS.
♪♪♪
AS I'M ABOUT TO PASS BY
THE JUDGES,
I'M GIVING THEM
MY FIERCEST WALK.
FORGET ALL THE SLIPS
THAT I HAD.
FORGET ME ALMOST
FALLIN' OFF THE RUNWAY.
THIS IS MY TIME RIGHT NOW
IN FRONT OF THEM.
♪♪♪
(laughs)
THIS IS IT--
YOUR LAST CHANCE
TO BE IN FRONT OF THEM
OR TO LOOK THE BEST.
IT WAS, LIKE,
"WHAT DO YOU WANT, JUDGES,
ME OR HER?"
THAT'S A GORGEOUS OUTFIT
FOR HER.
THIS IS GONNA BE THE FINALE.
SMILE, CLAP, LET'S GO.
♪♪♪
I AM AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
THERE'S NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT.
I FELT IT TODAY.
I AM GOING TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
OH, MY GOD!
WHOO, GOT A LITTLE TEARY.
- HOW WAS IT?
- AAH!
THAT WAS WORKIN' IT.
YOU WERE SLIPPIN',
BUT IT WAS COOL!
YOU WERE SO GOOD, OOH!
I'M SO PROUD OF YOU GIRLS.
YOU GUYS LOOK LIKE MODELS.
MM.
OKAY, COME WITH ME, GIRLS.
TO WALK THAT RUNWAY TODAY
WAS WHAT I EXPECTED IT TO BE,
AND EVEN MORE.
JUST THE LOVE THAT I WAS
FEELING FROM THE AUDIENCE
AND FROM THE JUDGES
WAS AMAZING.
HI!
- OH, YOU'RE SWEATING.
- OH, I KNOW.
I COULDN'T SEE IT.
THIS IS THE FIRST "TOP MODEL"
SHOW WHERE I WAS LIKE THIS.
LOOK AT THAT.
SHE'S GONNA CRY AGAIN.
I'M SO PROUD OF YOU,
AND I'LL SEE YOU GUYS
SOON, OKAY?
YOU KNOW, WHEN I SEE YOU,
I'LL BE LIKE THIS.
I KNOW.
AT THE RUNWAY,
SHE MADE ME CRY.
I'M LIKE, "OH, MY GOSH,
THIS IS, LIKE,
THE LAST THING IN
THE WHOLE COMPETITION.
I FEEL REALLY GOOD."
♪♪♪
I'LL READ IT.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY ONE OF YOU WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I'VE BEEN WAITIN'
SO MANY MONTHS
FOR THIS TIME RIGHT HERE,
AND I'M READY FOR IT.
- IT'S CRAZY.
- YEAH.
I'VE DONE A LOT TO BE HERE,
AND I-I-I WANT IT SO BAD.
THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE.
MM-HMM.
♪♪♪
- HI, JOANIE.
- HI.
HI, DANIELLE.
FIRST OF ALL, I WANNA
CONGRATULATE YOU BOTH.
YOU'VE COME A LONG WAY.
YOU, JOANIE, FROM
BEAVER FALLS, PENNSYLVANIA,
AND YOU, DANIELLE, FROM
LITTLE ROCK, ARKANSAS,
AND YOU'RE THE TWO FINALISTS.
SO, TONIGHT WE WILL DECIDE
WHO WILL BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU'VE HEARD THE PRIZES
EVERY SINGLE WEEK,
AND ONE OF YOU
IS ABOUT TO RECEIVE THEM.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT WITH
TOP INTERNATIONAL MODELING
MANAGEMENT COMPANY FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
MR. GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR YOUR
INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH YOUR RUNWAY WALKS
IN THE ISSUE FASHION SHOW,
AND, DANIELLE,
YOU'RE UP FIRST.
MISS J., DANIELLE
IS DOIN' YOUR WALK.
I WAS LOOKIN' AT MYSELF
IN DRAG.
DANIELLE,
LIKE A SEASONED PRO.
YOUR LITTLE WINK TO ME,
I WASN'T SURE
FOR A MOMENT THERE
BUT I WAS, LIKE,
"HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE,
IT WORKED."
I ALMOST HAD
A LITTLE TEAR.
YOU WERE JUST SO WONDERFUL.
ONE THING
I WOULD HAVE LIKED TO SEE,
A LITTLE MORE ALERTNESS
IN THE FACE.
SOMETIMES YOU LOOKED
A LITTLE BORED.
I WAS CONCENTRATING
ON NOT SLIPPING.
YOU ARE THE GIRL
THAT'S ACCIDENT PRONE.
I AM THAT GIRL.
CRUTCHES, HOSPITAL--
THAT'S ME, YEAH.
ALL RIGHT, JOANIE,
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO SEE YOU
IN THE FASHION SHOW.
I LOVE THE WALK.
JOANIE, I THOUGHT YOUR WALK,
PARTICULARLY THE ONE
WITH THE FEATHERS
IN YOUR HAIR...
(gasps)
TOOK MY BREATH AWAY.
WITH THE OTHER OUTFIT,
AT TIMES,
IT LOOKED LIKE YOU WERE
WALKIN' IN THE MALL.
I THOUGHT
YOUR WALK WAS FANTASTIC.
MY PROBLEM WITH YOU,
JOANIE,
WAS THE FACT THAT
YOU LOOKED DOWN TOO MUCH.
PHOTOGRAPHERS, THEY WANNA
SNAP A SHOT OF YOU,
AND IF YOU'RE LOOKIN'
DOWN AT THE GROUND,
ALL YOU SEE IS,
LIKE, SHUT EYES.
ALL RIGHTY.
THE REASON WHY YOU'RE STANDING
IN FRONT OF US RIGHT NOW
IS BECAUSE YOU TWO HAVE
DONE THE STRONGEST PICTURES
IN THIS ENTIRE COMPETITION.
SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE A LOOK
AT SOME OF YOUR BEST PHOTOS.
THE VERY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
THAT YOU DID WAS WHAT,
- YOU REMEMBER THAT ONE?
- THE BALD.
THE BALD PHOTOS.
WITH DANIELLE,
YOUR EYE CONTACT WAS
PARTICULARLY IMPRESSIVE TO ME,
'CAUSE YOU CONNECTED
WITH THE CAMERA IN A WAY
THAT A NEW MODEL RARELY DOES.
JOANIE'S EYES JUST SEAR
INTO YOUR SOUL.
I MEAN, I CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT WAS YOUR FIRST PHOTOGRAPH.
YOU GUYS WERE NOT JUST POSING
AS FAIRY TALE PRINCESSES,
BUT YOU WERE FALLING,
AND BOTH OF YOUR FACES
LOOKED TOTALLY IN CONTROL.
I ACTUALLY PREFERRED
DANIELLE'S CLOSEUP,
BUT I THINK JOANIE'S BODY
IN THIS IS EXTRAORDINARY.
DANIELLE,
MY ISSUE AT THIS POINT,
I WAS GETTING THE SAME LOOK
FROM YOU WEEK AFTER WEEK.
ONE WEEK, YOU WERE
PUPPETS AND DOLLS.
I LOVE THE BUSTED,
BROKEN DOWN DOLL LOOK.
THESE TWO PICTURES ARE
THE STRONGEST OF THAT WEEK,
BECAUSE YOU'RE DOING
A BLANK DOLL FACE,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
YOU'RE STILL REMEMBERING
THAT YOU'RE A MODEL.
ON YOUR HEAD,
LIKE YOU HAVE A HEADACHE, OH.
THE SAME WEEK, I DIRECTED YOU
IN A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO CRY.
A SHOT LIKE THIS
IS ALL ABOUT THEATRICS,
AND, JOANIE,
I BELIEVE YOU.
IT LOOKS LIKE A STILL
OUT OF A MOVIE.
DANIELLE JUST IS ELEGANT.
I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE
SEEN A LITTLE MORE...
SOMETHING BURNING.
DANIELLE,
I THINK YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT YOUR BEAUTY MORE,
BUT STILL EMOTIONAL,
AND JOANIE'S
FORGOTTEN ABOUT HER BEAUTY
AND THINKING ABOUT
THE EMOTION.
SO I JUST THINK
THEY'RE TWO DIFFERENT EMOTIONS,
BUT TO ME, THEY STILL
EVOKE SADNESS.
YOU HAD TO POSE
ON AN ELEPHANT.
YOU GUYS ARE ALMOST LIKE
OPPOSITES OF ONE ANOTHER,
FACING IN
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION,
LEGS GOING UP IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES, GIRLS.
I'M LOOKING AT YOU AND NOT
THE ELEPHANT, AND THAT'S HARD.
DANIELLE, TAKE US BACK TO
YOU BEING SICK THAT DAY.
I WAS DEHYDRATED
AND HAD FOOD POISONING,
SO I WAS WOOZY UP THERE
ON THE ELEPHANT
AND KIND OF DIZZY,
BUT I WANTED TO GET A GOOD SHOT.
YOU BOTH LOOK ACTUALLY VERY,
VERY COMFORTABLE UP THERE.
THE ANIMAL
WAS SUCH A GENTLE ANIMAL,
AND I REALLY DID BOND
WITH IT.
AW.
THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT
THAT YOU DID
WAS WITH THE NOTED
NIGEL BARKER.
YOU BOTH MAKE
THE SUN COME OUT
WHEN I TAKE PICTURES.
DANIELLE IS QUITE SEXY.
LOOK HOW DIFFERENT
JOANIE LOOKED.
THIS PICTURE BLEW ME
AWAY, JOANIE, ACTUALLY.
AND YOUR VERY LAST
PHOTO SHOOT.
I LOOK AT BOTH
OF THOSE PICTURES,
AND THEY'RE BOTH
COVERGIRL ADS.
DANIELLE,
JUST GORGEOUSLY LONG NECK.
WOW, I MEAN, SO BEAUTIFUL.
JOANIE, WHO USUALLY LOOKS
VERY YOUNG AND KIND OF SWEET,
YOU'VE GONE AND BECOME
SOPHISTICATED.
ANYTHING YOU WANNA SAY BEFORE
THE JUDGES START TO DELIBERATE?
I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOU ALL NOT GIVIN' UP ON ME.
I KNOW MY SPEECH IS NOT PERFECT,
MY COMMUNICATION IS NOT PERFECT,
BUT I'M WILLING
TO WORK ON THAT, LIKE,
I'M WILLING TO HIRE PEOPLE,
TO GET TAPES,
TO DO WHATEVER I HAVE
TO DO TO CORRECT THAT.
I, AS WELL, WOULD LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
A BEAUTIFUL SMILE AND
BUILDING MY CONFIDENCE,
BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
I HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH
FOR A LONG TIME.
SO IT MEANS A LOT TO ME.
WELL, NOW IT'S TIME FOR
THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'M GONNA STAND BEFORE YOU
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
SO WE HAVE
TWO VERY BEAUTIFUL GIRLS.
BOTH OF THEM ARE STRONG.
WHO IS STRONGER?
VERY, VERY DIFFERENT
FROM ONE ANOTHER.
DANIELLE--
BEAUTIFUL AMAZONIAN GIRL,
TALL, GREAT ON THE RUNWAY,
REALLY STRUTTED HER STUFF
FOR ME.
JOANIE--NOT AS STRONG
ON THE RUNWAY FOR ME.
BUT JOANIE PHOTOGRAPHS
LIKE A DREAM.
SHE'S GOT
SO MANY DIFFERENT LOOKS.
YEAH, THAT'S THE ONE THING
ABOUT JOANIE--CHAMELEON.
AND IT IS SO IMPORTANT
AS A MODEL
- TO BE A CHAMELEON...
- YES, IT IS.
BUT TO STILL
LOOK LIKE YOURSELF.
DANIELLE LOOKS
INCREDIBLY BEAUTIFUL,
BUT SHE DOESN'T CHANGE
AS MUCH.
SHE HAS A SIGNATURE LOOK.
WHAT IS DANIELLE'S LIFE
AS A COVER GIRL?
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
PRESUMABLY,
SHE WILL WORK ON THAT,
AND CAN WORK ON THAT.
I THINK DANIELLE'S
PRESENCE
IS A LOT MORE STRONGER
WHEN SHE ENTERS A ROOM
THAN JOANIE'S.
BUT IF I LOOKED
AT BOTH OF THEIR BOOKS,
I'D GO FOR JOANIE.
SHE'S VERY, VERY
COMMERCIAL.
I THINK SHE'D WORK
INCREDIBLY WELL
IN AMERICA AND IN EUROPE.
I THINK WE HAVE TWO GIRLS
THAT ARE BASICALLY
ALMOST RUNNING
NECK AND NECK.
OH, THIS IS HORRIBLE.
IT'S SO HARD.
I KNOW. THIS IS
THE TOUGHEST ONE WE'VE EVER HAD.
I DON'T THINK THE GIRLS'
PORTFOLIOS
HAVE EVER LOOKED THIS GOOD
AT THIS STAGE BEFORE.
- REALLY?
- NO.
I AGREE. MAN, Y'ALL.
♪♪♪
THIS HAS BEEN
A LONG JOURNEY.
THIS JOURNEY WILL SOON
COME TO AN END,
BUT FOR ONE OF YOU,
IT'S JUST THE BEGINNING.
WILL YOU PLEASE
STEP FORWARD?
I'M PROUD OF BOTH OF YOU.
YOU PREVAILED IN MIND, BODY,
AND SPIRIT AND PHOTOS
AND ON THE RUNWAY, TOO,
AND THAT'S WHY YOU STAND
BEFORE ME,
BUT NOW IT'S TIME TO FIND OUT
WHO'S AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE.
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
IS...
DANIELLE.
OH, MY...
HEY, THAT'S ME
IN THAT PICTURE.
OH, MY GOD, THAT'S ME.
OH, MY GOD,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GIVE ME A HUG, JOANIE.
I'M DISAPPOINTED.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN SO HAPPY
IF IT WAS ME, BUT I'M OKAY.
WORK IT. CONQUER IT.
THE BEST GIRL WON.
AAH!
I AM THE WINNER OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
MY LIFE HAS OFFICIALLY
CHANGED.
AND WE GONNA GET YOU
SOME VOICE LESSONS, GIRL.
MY MOTHER'S GONNA BE
SO HAPPY RIGHT NOW.
IT HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN EASY,
AND WE'VE HAD STRUGGLES,
WE'VE HAD UPS AND DOWNS.
RIGHT NOW IT KINDA--
IT DOESN'T SEEM REAL TO ME
BECAUSE I'VE HAD
SO MANY STRUGGLES,
AND I'VE HAD
A HARD KNOCK LIFE.
EVERYTHING HAPPENS
FOR A REASON,
AND I KNOW THAT GOD BLESSED ME
WITH THIS OPPORTUNITY,
AND WE DON'T HAVE
TO STRUGGLE ANYMORE.
I'M SO HAPPY RIGHT NOW, OH.
I'M A COVER GIRL, MOMMY.
I'M A COVER GIRL.
OH, MY GOSH.
THANK YOU!